ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูต้อง
พรุ่งนี้สบายดีไหมสบายดีค่ะแล้วกูต้องล่ะ
คะกูต้องเหนื่อยนิดหน่อยค่ะนิดหน่อยหรือ
มากๆ
วันนี้ออกไปข้างนอกไปทำงานมาค่ะต่อ
เฮ้ยกูต้มวันนี้เนี่ยเดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวนะกู
เองเขา Share  screen ก่อนค่ะวันนี้ปากกา
คู๋ออกอยู่นี่นี่หาประกาศ
แล้วนะคะคู๋ขยายครูก่อนซื้อให้ครูใหญ่ๆหา
ค่า
วันนี้คุณต้อมวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรนะวัน
นี้วันอาทิตย์ถ้ากูเอ๋วันอาทิตย์เนี่ย
คุณต้องวันอาทิตย์ทำงานก็
ทำงานนิดหน่อยไปอาทิตย์จะจากบ้านใช่มั้ย
บ้านเนี่ยกูต้องออกไปข้างนอกทำงาน
สภาขอบคุณข้างนอกทำงานนิดหน่อยประจำค่ะมี
งานงานงานงานมากๆ
152 งาน 3 ชั้น 4 โดยใช่ไหม 4
ขยันกูต้องขยันว่ามาก
กูต้องวันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่นะ
คะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ที่
29 ค่ะ 29
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมปิดนิพ.ต.ต.อะไรคะพ.ศ
2020  2 ค่ะแล้วปีพตอะไรคะ
2565 ค่ะ 2 คันขอให้ร้อย 65
ที่ครู a ถามผู้ต้องว่าเหนื่อยไหมเนี่ย
ตอนนี้ที่เราเจอกันเวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เวลา
9:00 นยังๆกูต้อง 20:00 น 20:00 น 48
นาทีค่ะ
สองทุ่มสี่สิบแปดนาทีถ้าคุณต้องพูด 21:00
นเดี๋ยวกูเอกก็คิดอ้อ 9:30 เสร็จ
2 ทุ่ม 40  8 นาทีตอนกลางคืนนะคะกลางคืน
นะคะโอเคกูต้องดื่มน้ำหรือยังดื่มน้ำยัง
เลยไม่เอาน้ำไม่ได้ลืม
ข้อโอเคนะ
นิดหน่อยค่ะอยู่หน่อยนะพูดเสียงโอเคนะคะ
โอเคค่ะอ่ะคะเป็นห่วงค่ะนักเรียนภาษาไทย
เป็นห่วงนะทำ
โอเคค่ะคุณต้อมวันนี้หน้าคู๋อยากจะให้นัก
เรียนน่ะฟังแล้วก็รู้จักเกี่ยวกับ
วิธีคิดในคนไทยคนไทยคิดอะไร
เกี่ยวกับปีเกิดนะคะปีเกิดเนี่ยเดี๋ยวคุย
ลบตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะของคุณต้อมบอกได้ไหมอ่า
กูเห็นไม่ถามอายุคะนักเรียนกูเองมายุ
ครูต้องอายุกี่ปีอันเนี้ย
ไม่ถามแต่ว่าจะบอกว่าคนไทยน่ะเวลาเกิดใช่
ไหมมีคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่และคุณแม่แต่งงานกันแล้วพอท้องท้อง
ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็คลอดออกมาเนี่ยคลอดครูต้อม
ออกมา
ฮะอ่ะปีอะไรเนี่ยครูมีให้ดู 12 ปี
จะเรียนได้ไหมเนี่ยเดือนมั้ยล่ะเรื่องไม่
ได้ขอครูเล็กๆแล้วกันนะคะขอบคุณเล็กๆค่ะ
ก็มีก็ได้ค่ะกูไหมกูเห็นเลื่อนครูมาไว้
ตรงนี้
แต่กูต้องไม่เห็นว่าคุยเลื่อนครูใช่มั้ย
ไม่เห็นค่ะ
โอเคไม่เป็นไรอะคุณต้อมคะกูต้อมเนี่ยเอ่อ
เกิดปีอะไรคะอ่ะปีที่ 1 คุยนี่ปีที่ 1 ปี
อะไรคะปีหนูค่ะเอาชื่อสัปปะปีที่ 2 ค่ะ
นี่วัวปีที่ 3 ค่ะปีเสือปีที่ 4 ค่ะอีกก็
ต่ายดีที่ 5
ปีมังกร
ก็บดถ้าขยันมือของหน้าขยะหน้าพญานาคจ้า
ใช่คนไทยเรียกงูใหญ่นะใช่คนไทยเลขงูใหญ่
ปีงูใหญ่แต่ปีพญานาคพญานาคโอเคแต่ว่าถ้า
เป็นไทยจีนก็จะเป็นตัวนี้มังกรก่อนเลยมี 2
ตัวนะคะพญานาคกับมังกรนะคะปีงูใหญ่นะคะๆ
ปีที่ 6 ค่ะนี้มีงู
ดีที่ 7 ค่ะดีมากปีที่ 8 ค่ะ
EP แพะแบะ
ปีที่ 9 ค่ะ
ลิงค์
ปีที่ 10 ค่ะ
ไก่
ปีที่ 11 ค่ะพอดีหมาปีที่ 12 ค่ะมี
หมูโอ๋แล้วทำไมคุณต้องชี้ตัวเองคุณต้อง
อ้วนเป็นหมู
ไก่พูดหมู
ใช่ไหมโอเคราคาคนไทยปัจจุบันบางคนไม่ได้
นะคะแต่คุณต้องกับคู๋โอเคเป็นคน
พูดต้องแล้วครูต้องเกิดมาในปีอะไรคะนาย 12
ปีขอกูต้องเกิดปีไก่ค่ะอันนี้ครูตอมคะครู
ต้อมโอเค
แล้วคู่เอ๋นะคะเกิดปีอะไรกูเอกใกล้ๆขูด
อ่อมปีลิงอ๋อ
ปีลิงราคาอันนี้คู๋คุณต้องปีไก่งั้นคุณ
ต้อมก็น้องน้องๆครูอีก 1 ปีใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะนะคะที่นี้นักเรียนก็รู้แล้วอันนี้คุย
เลือนเพื่อนกูต้มมัดไว้ด้านนี้ได้ละมาดู
ปีที่หนึ่งเลยคือนักเรียนคะคนไทยเนี่ยก็
จะมีมีความเชื่ออยู่ 1 ความเชื่ออาจเป็น
ของคนไทยเมื่อก่อนนะคะเป็นคนไทยมาก่อนอ่า
ที่นี้เนี่ยเป็นความเชื่อเกี่ยวกับต้นไม้
ครูต้อมหมอ
เป็นความเชื่อเกี่ยวกับต้นไม้เกี่ยวกับ
บ้านนอกบ้านมีบ้านนะคะบ้านแล้วเกิดปีนี้
ต้องปลูกต้นไม้อะไรแล้วดีอ๋อ
ต้องแม่ต้องรู้ว่าเกิดเกิดปีอะไรปลูกต้น
ไม้อะไรแล้วโชคดีขอที่ที่หมอเทศไทยก็จะมี
คนไทยคนไทยจีนซึ่งความหมายของคนไทยกับไทย
จีนก็ไม่เหมือนกันเหมือนกันแต่วันนี้ครู
เอกจะเอาความคิดแบบคนไทยนะคะถ้าแล้วก็
กลับปีเกิดอ่ะเป็นต้นไม้แล้วก็ปีเกิดใช่
ไหมอันนี้ต้นไม้อ่ะนิด Eagle ปีที่ 1 มี
อะไรนะคะคุณต้อมหนูค่ะหนูนะคะปีที่ 1
เป็นหนูนะครับ
เฮ้ยให้ครูต้อมลองคิด
ต้องอาจจะเห็นแล้ว
ถึงปีที่ 1 ถ้าเกิดที่บ้านมีคนเกิดปีหนู
ที่บ้านคุณต้องมีไหมมีใครเกิดปีหนูไหมไม่
มีเลยค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไม่มีอ่ะปีที่ 1 นะคะแล้ว
ของครูต้อมปีที่ 10 อยู่ข้างล่างเดี๋ยวกู
ถ่ายรอนะคะต้องโอเคค่ะนักเรียนมีใครมีใคร
คุยเสียมีใครเกิดปีหนูคอมเม้นข้างล่างนะ
คะ
ก็ปีหนูนะคะคุณต้อมเขาบอกว่าถ้าจะให้โชค
ดีนะคะที่บ้านเนี่ยที่บ้านต้องปลูกไม่ใช่
ต้นไม้ตอนนี้
คุยว่าลบอันนี้ออก
ต้องปลูก
ต้น
มะพร้าวค่าครูต้อมอ๋อ
มะพร้าว
หน้าเหมือนไหม
เหมือนค่ะโอเคนะเรามาดูว่าเหมือนไหม
โอ้โหเหี๊ย
เท้าลูกเยอะมากได้อะนี้ตกมะพร้าวแพงอัน
นี้ลูกมะพร้าวนะครับต้นหนาวเอาสีแดงดี
กว่าสีชมพูอ่ะลูกมะพร้าวต้นมะพักที่สองสี
ด้วยคุณต้องเห็นอ๋อมะพร้าวสีอะไรครับตอน
นี้สีเขียวค่ะลูกมะพร้าวสีเขียวแล้วก็น่า
สีอะไรค่ะต้อนมีลูกมะพร้าวสีเหลืองสี
เหลืองเราบอกว่าสีทองสีทองสีทองหรือสี
เหลืองสีทองสีเหลืองจากเค้าเรียกมะพร้าว
ใฝ่มะพร้าวไฟๆกับเขาเคยได้ยินเขาเรียก
มะพร้าวไฟเขาบอกว่ากินแล้วแข็งแรง
ขอ
แรงคนที่ไม่ว่าจะจริงไม่จริงไม่ทราบนะคะ
แต่ว่าที่แน่ๆคนเกิดปีหนูน่ะปีหนูน่ะจะ
ต้องปลูกมะพร้าวที่บ้าน
แล้วไม่ใช่มะพร้าวอย่างเดียวคุณต้องค่ะมี
อะไรคะก็มีปลูกกล้วยด้วยค่ะอ๋อ
โอเครับปลูกก็คือมีดินนะคะมีที่นี่แล้วก็
เอาต้นกล้วยมาถ้าพูดโคตรแล้วก็ปลูกลงไป
แล้วก็ขึ้นตั้งแต่ต้นเล็กๆนะคะต้นเล็กๆ
จักก็มาต้นสูงแบบนี้ต้องปลูกต้นมะพร้าว
กับต้นกล้วย
กูต้อมไม่ด้วยนะครูเอ๋ไอ้กินได้กูต้องคิด
ว่าบ้านครูเอ๋น่ะมีไหมคะ
ว่าครูเอ๋มีแน่นอน
บ้านครูเอ๋นะคะนักเรียนแม่น่ะปีหนู
หลานแม่แล้วก็มีลูกพี่สาวกูเอ๋
มีลูกสาวก็ปีหนู
ที่บ้านครูเอ๋นี่แหละค่ะก็เลยมีมะพร้าว
ใครไม่รู้เอาพร้าวเต็มบ้านแล้วพิมพ์พระ
อันนี้ครูเอ๋หรือเปล่าคะไปใช้กับไว้ซะพี่
สาวพี่สาวให้อาหารปลา
ที่ตรงนี้เป็นสระน้ำแล้วก็มีปลา
มีปลาพี่สาวจะเอาอาหารไปให้ปลาวันนี้พี่
สาวมาแล้วก็เนี่ยเห็นนะคะคุณต้อมต้น
มะพร้าวมะพร้าวมะพร้าวมะพร้าว
อันนี้สระน้ำแล้วก็มีมะพร้าวรอบสระน้ำเลย
ค่ะเฮ้ยเยอะมากไอ้ตั้มไปได้แม่บอกใครจะ
เอาโอเคแต่ขึ้นเองนะ
ตีนใช่คุณแม่บอกเหนื่อยดีขึ้นไม่ได้ก็จะ
มีเป็นมะมีมะพร้าวนะคะรอบๆแล้วก็มีต้น
กล้วยตรงนี้ถ้าแล้วก็มีสวนกล้วยแบบนี้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
มุกกล้วยสูงเท่าๆมะพร้าว
กะซิบมีแต่ต้นไม่มีลูก
คือแม่ไม่ตัดแม่ขึ้นขึ้นขึ้นก็เลยไม่
มีลูกมีลูกนิดหน่อยมีแต่ต้น
แล้วครูเอกไปตัดของคุณแม่ไม่ได้นะเอาไป
อ่ะน่าจะโกรธต้นกล้วยดีดีคุณแม่บอกอ๋อไม่
ให้ตัดได้มาไม่ให้ตัดถ้าแม่ตัดเองโอเค
แม่บอกว่าดีนะคะอ่ะกันปีหนูนะคะกูต้อมนัก
เรียนเราก็จะปลูกมะพร้าวแล้วก็ปลูกกล้วย
ผู้โชคดีปีที่ไหน
ปีที่ 2 ปีอะไรคะคุณต้อง 2 ปีวัวค่ะปีวัว
ที่บ้านครูต้อมมีใครเกิดปีวัวไหมคะ
มีน้องชายคนนึงค่ะอ๋อต้องคิดว่าเกิดปีวัว
นะคุณต้องรู้ไหม
เกิดปีวัวต้องปลูกต้นอะไรโชคดีใหมค่ะนี่
ค่ะกูต้อง
อะไรคะ
เห็นไหมต้นตามหรอใช่ต้นตาลเอาง้อให้คล้าย
มะพร้าวเนาะนั่งเล่นใครขายถือไม่ไม่ไม่
เหมือนน่ะไม่เหมือนห่าแต่แต่เนื้อต้นตาล
อันเนี้ยลูกตาล
ลูกตาลกินได้นะคะเพราะว่าอร่อยอ่ะนี้นะคะ
อร่อยคู๋
ต้องจริงๆเราอร่อยคนต่างชาติไม่อร่อยล้อ
ตัวเอกเคยเอาลูกตาลให้นักเรียนกินนัก
เรียนเอ้ยไม่อะไร
แต่กูต้องกับครูเอ๋น่ะคิดว่าอร่อยค่ะ
ลุลูกครูต้องกินไหมคะ
ไม่กินค่ะไม่อร่อยใช่ไหมไม่อร่อยชอบกิน
มันฝรั่ง
เป็นวันนักเรียนแต่ละคนคิดไม่เหมือนกัน
ครูต้อมกับพูห์ a นะคิดอร่อยนะคะแบบเด็กๆ
จะบอกไม่อร่อยก็
ถ้าเกิดปีวัวนะคะเกิดปีวัวต้อง
ปลูกต้นตาลแล้วโชคดี
ค่ะกูต้องบอกน้องชายปลูกต้นโครงการหรู
ต้นตาลสูงมากคุยสูงมาก
อยู่กรุงเทพปลูกได้ไหม
ไม่น่าจะปลูกได้นะนะๆนักเรียนหรือถ้าจะ
ปลูกต้นไม้แบบนี้ต้องอยู่ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯ
ถ้าอยู่กรุงเทพฯก็ต้องมีบ้านแล้วก็มีมี
บ้านแบบนี้กูอีกเรื่องตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะ
Love
คงต้องมีมีบ้าน
เราก็มีที่ดิน
ว่างเนาะว่างๆ
จะได้ปลูกเอาต้นตาลมาไว้ตรงนี้ได้
เอาต้นตาลเอาไว้ตรงนี้ได้นะคะ
ก็จะมีต้นตาลได้มีแต่ถ้าเป็นบ้านที่ไม่
ไม่ไม่ไม่กว้างมาก
ก็จะปลูกต้นตาลไม่ได้เนาะมีค่ายค่ะไม่
เป็นไรเอารูปต้นตาลขอ
มาต่อไปค่ะคุณน้องค่ะปีอะไรกิน
หัวค่ะปี 4 เหลือนะคะปีเสือนี่ปีเสือเขา
ให้ปลูกต้นนี้ค่ะครูต้อมโอ้โหต้นอะไรขนุน
อ่ะต้นขนนนะคะอันนี้ต้อลขนนหลักนักเรียน
และนักเรียนจะคิดทุเรียนไม่ใช่นะคะไม่ใช่
ขนมจะเป็นแบบนี้อันนี้เป็นอะไรคะครูต้อม
ตัวนี้เปลือกค่ะทั้งหมดตรงเนี๊ยลูกลูกลูก
ขนุนลูกขนุนแล้วก็แกะออกมาตัวนี้เรียกว่า
อะไรคะ
เนื้อเนื้อขนนเราจะพูดว่ายูงขนน
ง้อเป็นยวงแล้วนั้นเป็นดวงอยู่ยังขนุน
หรือบางทีพูดเนื้อขนนโอเคฮะกินได้เนาะกิน
ได้อร่อยกูทำอร่อย
หวานด้วยค่ะ
ผอมคนไทยบอกขอหอมนะก็
หวานชายคนไทยหอมนะคะนักเรียนคิดอะไรมั้ย
พูห์
บางคนไม่ชอบแต่ครูต้อมกับตัวเอชอบ
คนเกิดปีเสือต้องปลูก
ขนนหนุนตาขนุนที่บ้าน
ต่อไปอรุณไปอ่ะถ้ามีอะไรเอาจ่อมปีกระต่าย
ปีกระต่าย
คนที่เกิดปีกระต่ายเนี่ยต้องปลุกปลุกอะไร
ที่บ้านครับกูต้ม
มะพร้าวเหรอคะใช่ค่ะกระต่ายกับหนูเหมือน
กัน
ได้ปลูกมะพร้าวที่บ้านเรา
นะคะตอบที่บ้านคุณต้องมีใครเกิดปีเสือ
มั้ยทีนี้เสือไม่มีค่ะอ่ะอีกกระต่ายป่าย
ไม่มีค่ะโอเคค่ะกลับไปค่ะปีอะไรคะคุณต้อม
ดียิ่งใหญ่อ้ะปีงูใหญ่หรือปีนาคนะคะหน้า
พญานาคหรือมังกรก็ได้เอ่อแต่เนื่องจากวัน
นี้เราแบบไทยเราก็ปีพญานาคมีคนเกิดปีพญา
นาคต้องปลูกอะไรที่บ้านคะครูต้อม
ต้นไผ่ค่ะอ่าใช่ต้นไผ่แบบนี้
ต้นไผ่
บ้านเก่าคู๋มีมีต้นไผ่บ้านตอนนี้ไม่มี
บ้านคุณต้องมีไหมไม่มีค่ะบ้านกูต้องไม่มี
คนเกิดปีพญานาคใช่ไหมแล้วบ้านครูต้อมไม่
มีที่ก็กว้างๆบ้านคุณต้องที่เล็กๆขออีก
ตอนถ่ายไม่ได้ค่ะ
ไข่แคระอุดต้อมอ๋ออ๋อเหรอคะเค้าจะมีไผ่
แบบนี้ค่ะในกระถางวิเคราะห์วิเคราะห์สี
เขียว
แบบนิแล้วก็ไผ่ขึ้นมาอ๋อ
ไข่เล็กๆ
มีต้นไม่เคยเห็นไอ้เล็กๆค่ะมีวีด้าแต่ถ้า
คนคิดแล้วก็อยู่กรุงเทพฯหรืออยากปลูกต้อง
ซื้อไผ่เล็กๆมาปลุก
แปล 8 ขนนไม่มีต้นเล็กๆ
มะพร้าวไม่มีต้นเล็กๆ
อ่ะต่อไปค่ะ
ปีปีทูปีที่ 7 นะคะปีงูอะไรคะงูเล็กค่ะ
งูเล็กคุณต้อมรู้ไหมต้องปลูกต้นอะไร
งูเล็กก็ปลูกต้นไผ่เหรอคะเหมือนกันเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะต้องปลูกต้นไผ่เหมือนปีงูใหญ่
รัดๆๆโชคดีนะค่ะโชคดี
ตีนะ
ไข่มันสีเขียวเนาะสีเขียวกูต้องชอบไผ่ไหม
อ่ะแต่กูต้องชอบไผ่ไม้ไผ่ค่ะลายลายสวยวัน
นี้ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะชอบชอบไม้ไผ่ฤลำต้นของไผ่
หอม
High ค่ะ
ต่อไปนะคะปีต่อไป
กูอีกไปเร็วไปไม่มีอะไรคะปีต่อไปตีนี้ม้า
ปีม้านะครับปีมา
ปีม้า
นี่คู๋ขายพี่สาวนะคะ
คนนี้เกิดปีม้า
ค่ะเกิดปีม้าอาบปีมาเนี่ย
กลับมาซื้อ
รับปีม้าครูต้อมรู้ไหมคะว่าปีมากต้องปลูก
ต้นอะไร
แม่ปลูกด้วย
โหปลูกต้นกล้วยนะคะแล้วโชคดี
ตั้ง
บ้านครูเอ๋มีปีหนู
มีพี่หนูเนี่ยหนู 2 คน
ปีมา 1 คน
เข้าใจทำไมมีต้นกล้วยมากๆ
ค่ะมี 3 คนใช่มาสามคนที่ถ้าที่บ้านแล้ว
ปลูกต้นกล้วย
จะนะคะโชคดีอ้อเข้าใจทำไมคุณแม่ปลูกกล้วย
มากๆๆค่ะวันนี้เพิ่งเข้าใจ
เราไปนี่
มีอะไรคะครูต้อมอีแพะค่ะ 5 ปีแพะปีแพะ
เนี่ย
ต้องปลูกต้นอะไรที่บ้านแล้วโชคดีค่ะอัน
นี้ต้นไผ่หรือเปล่าคะใช่ค่ะแต่เป็นไผ่ไม่
เหมือนไผ่
อะดิ
อันนี้ต้นไผ่สวยๆใช่ไหมคะถ้าอันนี้เขาบอก
เป็นเบอร์ที่บ้านครูเอ๋เลี่ยงไผ่สีสุกไผ่
สีสุกแต่เขาเรียกไข่ป่าไผ่ที่อยู่ในภูเขา
อ่ะกูต้อมอ๋อ
มันจะมีมีแบบนี้มีเล็กๆแบบนี้แล้วบางทีมี
มีหนามด้วยนะมีแบบนี้
หนูอ่ะน่ารักอ่ะเนี่ยเป็นไผ่ป่านะคะไผ่
ป่า
คนเกิดปีแพ็คต้องปลูกไผ่ป่าที่บ้านเวลา
ครูเอ๋เด็กๆที่บ้านมีไผ่ป่าไผ่สีสุกก็มี
ไผ่ตัวนี้สองแบบเลย
เพราะว่าอันนี้พี่ชายค่ะพ่อ
แม่เราก็พี่สาวพี่สาวก็กล้วยแม่ก็กล้วย
ถ้าๆพี่ชายก็ไข่
พูดเอ๋คะไผ่ป่าต้นเล็กต้นใหญ่เค้าใหญ่มาก
ง่วงกับเนี่ยค่ะ
แต่ถ้าไผ่แต่นั้นก็จะต้นเล็กๆ
[เพลง]
ใหญ่กูต้องเหนื่อยไข่อันนี้เหนื่อยทาง
เห็นไหมๆที่บ้านถ้าไม่มีตัวเองนะกลัวขอ
ที่บายโคตรทำไมอ่ะเอ่อกลัวงูงูเวลาเดิน
น้อยจับก็เจ็บนะคะ
จะมีไผ่ตัวนี้นะคะกอใหญ่มากอ่ะเร็วเรียก
ว่าหนึ่งกอมีต้นแล้วก็ต้นต้นใหญ่อ่ะกูขอ
ใหญ่ประมาณนี้แหละค่ะบางทีกว้างออกมา
ประมาณเท่าไรอ่ะสิ่งนี้เอาหู 2 แม่เนี่ย
คะกล่องเมตร
ใช่อุ่นใหญ่มากใหญ่มากพรุ่งนี้ก็จะก่อน
ใครอันนี้กูเป็นไผ่ป่าเขาบอกโชคดีแอดโค๊ะ
บอกว่าเหนื่อย
ว่าต้อง
กวาดเวลาใบตรงนี้ไปอ่ะ
ร่วงเนี่ยต้องกว่าถ้าไปร่วงลงมาอ่ะอุ้ยขอ
โทษค่ะ
ใบต่อกันร่วงลงมาเนี่ยต้องขวาดกว่า
เหนื่อย
คุณพ่อบอกว่าดีกว่าปอ่ะแข็งแรงขอให้ออก
กำลัง
ใช่ดูไทยดีใจ
ไปพูดต่อค่ะ
ต่อไปปีลิงปีนี้ปีลิงนะคะกูต้องปีลิง
เนี่ยต้องปลูกต้นอะไรคะอันนี้ต้นขนนต้น
ขนน
เวลาอีกใช้ทุเรียนไปใช่ไม่ใช่ครูเอ๋ปี
อะไรคุณต้องจำได้ไหมกูเอ๋ปีลิง 5 ปีลิง
อ่ะเวลาคุยเด็กๆที่บ้านกูเอ๋เอ๋มีต้นขนน
คุณคิดว่าคุณแต่ก็นะลูก 1 คนก็ปลูก 1 ต้น
มิกล้วยสำหรับพี่สาวอ่ะค่ะมีมะพร้าว
สำหรับพี่สาวถ้า
มีอะไรนะมีไผ่ต้นไผ่นิตอนนี้สำหรับพี่ชาย
นะคะพี่ชายครูเอ๋ขอครูเอ๋ลิงนะคะลิงก็พอ
กะปลูกขนุน
ถนนสำหรับครูเอ๋นิบ้านใหม่ไม่มี
ทีหนึ่งต้นหนึ่งต้นแล้วเมื่อก่อนคุณพ่อ
ปลูกถนนจะมี 2 ต้น 3
[เพลง]
อะไรคะหาวค่าครู ah บอกคู๋ว่าพี่คอนโดที่
คอนโดของครูต้อมเนี่ยมีต้นขนุนอยู่สารต้น
ค่ะ
กุ้งกูต้องคิดว่าพี่คงก็รอคนไทยหลายๆคน
คิดว่าต้นขนุนเวลาปลูกในบ้านเยอะๆแล้วดี
ใช่ๆชื่อขนนเนี่ยขนนดีหนุน R  R ขึ้นชาย
ให้ขึ้นโชคดีนะคะเขาก็เลยปลูกต้นขนุนนะคะ
อันนี้แปลว่าเจ้าของที่เขาดูเป็นคนไทยทุก
คนตาย High ค่ะต่อไปค่ะกดต้อมอันนี้ที่
บ้านกูเองไม่มีเฮ้ยปีไก่แฮปปี้ไก่พี่ไก่
กุ๊กตอนนี้ค่ะกูต้อมอะไรคะต้นยางค่ะ
จะเป็นต้นยางนานะต้นยางไทยราคาไม่ใช่ต้น
ยางที่ที่ไปกรีดแล้วเอาน้ำไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อันนี้ต้นยางต่อไปนะคะมันจะ
มีต้นยางอีกอย่างนึงที่เป็นแบบนี้ค่ะนัก
เรียนแล้วเขากรีดตรงนี้แล้วก็จะมีปีน้ำ
ยาง
เอาน้ำยาไปทำล้อล้อรถน่ะค่ะ
น้ำยาอันนี้เอาไปทำล้อรถอันนั้นไม่ใช่
ต้องเป็นต้นอย่างไทยอ๋อก็เลยไม่มีใครปลูก
ถ้ามันกินไม่ได้
เหรอคะแล้วอันนี้อะไรคะสีน้ำตาลลูกอย่าง
ค่ะ
กินได้มั้ยคะกินไม่ได้ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อกูต้องเคย
เห็นที่เขาเล่นวอน
มั้ยคะได้ค่ะมันจะหมุน
หมุนตกลงมาแบบนั้นน่ะกินให้เห็นในทีวี
แต่ต้นยางก็ดีการปลูกก็ดีดีดีเพราะว่า
สามารถตัดแล้วก็เอามาทำบ้านได้อ๋อแข็งแรง
ได้ก็แข็งแรงนะแข็งแรงแต่ทั้งนี้ขอโทษไม่
คะคู่เห็ดปากผมประการตกจะบอกว่าต้นยาง
ใหญ่คะแต่ก็เล็กแล้วก็ใหญ่ๆขึ้น
อีก 2 ปีออกไปมีอะไรคะนี่หมาแล้วปีอะไรคะ
หมูอาปีหมากับปีหมูเนี่ยปลูกต้นไม้เหมือน
กันครูต้อมขอ
ต้นนี้ค่ะ
ดอกบัวๆดอกบัวหลวงดอกบัวนะคะปีหมากับปี
หมูก็ปลูกดอกบัวน่ารักโชคดีนะคะเอาไปไหว้
พระใช่มั้ยไหว้พระได้ไม่พระสาธุ
มีพระเนี่ย
เอาไปไหว้พระได้กินได้ใช่มั้ยได้ด้วยนะคะ
นักเรียนวันนี้นักเรียนก็ก็รู้จักอ่ะคน
อาบปีเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะสัตว์กับปีเกิด
ราคะสัตว์กับปีเกิด 12 ปีนะคะที่คนไทยจะ
รู้ว่าตัวเองเกิดปีสัดอะไรราคะครูต้อมก็
ปีอีกไก่ให้คุณต้องปีไก่
ไม่ได้กู้
ไม่ได้นะคะมาน่ะก็ไม่เป็นไรคุณต้อมกูต้อง
ก็คิดแบบคนจีนก็ได้มีไทยแล้วก็แบบตีนถ้า
มีต้นไม้ใหญ่ไม่ได้ปลุกตอนนี้ค่ะ
อ๋อ
อันนี้เรียกต้นอะไรคุณต้องรู้จักไหมวง
เซียนนะคะให้ใช่
โป๊ยเซียนใช่ปะคือต้นโป๊ยเซียนก็กูต้อม
ปลูกได้คุ่ปลูกได้อ่าไปแต่คนจีนก็มีบอก
ว่าคนเกิดปีอะไรปลูกอะไรโชคดีมีเหมือนกัน
นะคะคือนักเรียนต้นไม้ที่คนไทยเชื่อว่า
ปลูกดีดีกับวันเกิดเนี่ยปีเกิดน่ะจะเป็น
ต้นไม้อย่าง
แต่จะมีต้นไม้อีกเยอะๆเลยที่ปลูกแล้วโชค
ดีนะคะ
ปลูกแล้วโชคดีแต่ไม่ใช่ต้นไม้ใหญ่ราคาแต่
วันนี้เรายังไม่ได้สอนเพราะว่าเวลาหมด
เรียนมันก็คุณต้อมอยู่กรุงเทพฯจะไปปลูก
มะพร้าวปลูกกล้วยปลูกขนมได้ก็จะมีต้นไม้
ตัวเล็กนะคะเล็กๆที่ปลูกแล้วโชคดีนะคะที่
ประเทศไทยต้นไม้เล็กๆบางอย่างที่ปลูกแล้ว
โชคดีนะ
แพงมาก
นะแพงมากไว้คลิปหน้าหน้าครูเอ๋จะเอาต้น
ไม้ที่คนไทยคิดว่าปลูกแล้วโชคดีที่แพงๆ
ให้เรียนดูนะคะเก๋ตอนนี้ครูต้มขอปลูกต้น
ไม้นี้ไปก่อนนะคะต้นไม้ต้นไม้อะไรคะอัน
นี้ปลูกข้าวต้ม
อันนี้ไม่ได้ปลูกอันนี้เป็นพลาสติก
ตอนบายพาสสติ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้คุณก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะขอบคุณ
ค่ะคุณต้องสวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนบ๊ายบายค่ะ